Now that we know how to structure our code to replicate and we can choose which network replication framework we want to use
But how do we go about actually testing our game? Do we have to generate a build every time?
Well, the answer to this question is yes, but also no
The editor is one of the few special configurations that we can build that will contain both server and client code
The reason for this is that the editor can spin up a server as well as multiple clients to give us a representation
of our networked game
We can also simulate bad ping to see how our gameplay and network systems react when under specific conditions
We can also provide the server with custom launch parameters from within the editor directly
But whilst it will give us a good representation of our network game do not solely rely on this as a method of testing
Frequent builds must also be worked into your workflow as they can have discrepancies with what the editor actually presents
So before we end let's take a look at some of the options that we can control from within the editor
There's actually a lot of options in here
But some of the key fields that we need to look at are the number of playing clients
This defines the number of clients to spawn in the game when launched and the editor and listen server count as players whilst the
dedicated server does not
Next we can enable network simulation and if ticked this will enable the options below which allow us to choose different network profiles and
Target to simulate them on this is essentially how we go about simulating bad ping for example
Finally, we've got the play net mode and we have one of three options
We can play as a client where we will launch as a client as well as a dedicated server
Which is going to run as a separate process in the background
Next we've got play standalone and it's going to launch us as a standalone game meaning no server at all
Finally, we've got play as listen server and this is going to launch the game with the first client acting as both the server
and its own client
We're then free to just hit play like we would otherwise and the answer is going to spin up as many clients as we requested
And boot up a server in the background to coordinate all of them that concludes introduction to networking in Unreal Engine for programmers
Today we learned about the server client model and how in reels game architecture interacts with it
We looked at replication both functional and variable
We looked at optimization strategies with relevancy and dormancy before moving on to environment queries with the net role and net mode
We learned about the act replication flow and the replication graph
Before wrapping up with traveling and testing in multiplayer using unreal's inbuilt tools. Thank you so much for watching and have a fantastic day